a particle moving in the x y plane has
velocity vector given by v of t is equal
to all of this business and so using
this notation it just means that the x
component of velocity is as a function
of time is one over t plus seven and the
y component of velocity as a function of
time is t to the fourth for time t
greater than or equal to zero
at t equals one the particle is at the
point three comma four
so the first part is what is the
magnitude of the displacement of the
particle between time t equals one and t
equals three and then we need to figure
out its position we need to round to the
nearest tenth so like always pause this
video and i think you will have to use a
calculator but pause this video and try
to work through it on your own
so we've done questions like this in one
dimension but now we're doing it in two
dimensions but the key is is to just
break it up into the component
dimensions so what we really want to do
is let's find the displacement in the x
direction so really just the change in x
and then let's just find the
displacement in the vertical direction
or our change in y and then we can use
those essentially using the pythagorean
theorem to find the magnitude of the
total displacement and also if we know
the change in x and change in y we just
add the change in x to the 3 and we add
the change in y to the 4 to find the
particle's position at time t equals 3.
so let's figure it out so change in x
from t equals 1 to t equals 3 well
that's just going to be the integral
of the rate function in the x direction
from time equal 1 to time equals 3. so
in the x direction we have 1 over t plus
7 that's our x velocity as a function of
time
1 over t plus 7
dt
and what is this going to be equal to
well you might want to do u substitution
if you're unfamiliar but you might
recognize that the derivative of t plus
7 is just 1 so you could think of this
as 1 times 1 over t plus 7. and so we
really can just take the anti-derivative
then with respect to t plus 7 so you get
the natural log of the absolute value of
t
plus 7.
and we are going to evaluate that at 3
and then subtract from that it evaluated
at 1. so this is going to be natural log
of the absolute value of 10 which is
just the natural log of 10
minus the natural log of the absolute
value of 8 which is just the natural log
of 8 which is equal to the natural log
of 10 over 8 just using our logarithm
properties which is equal to the natural
log of 1.25
so i can get my calculator out in a
second to calculate that
actually let's just well i'll do that in
a second and then let's figure out our
change in y
our change in y
once again we're going to take the
integral from 1 to 3 that's our change
that's our time
the time over which we're thinking about
the change and then what is the y
component of our velocity what's t to
the fourth
dt
well this is going to be
take the reverse power of rule t to the
fifth over 5
at 3 and 1. so this is 3 to the 5th over
5 is 243
over 5 minus 1 to the fifth over 5 minus
1 5th
so this is equal to
242 over 5 which is what 48.4
48.4
let me get my calculator out for this
natural log of 1.25
1.25
natural log and we'll just round to two
decimal places approximately 0.22
so this is approximately 0.22
so i figured out our change in x and our
change in y and actually just from that
we can answer the second part of the
question first what is the particle's
position at t equals three
what's going to be our position at t
equals one where we to each of the
components we add the the respective
change so we would add so this would be
three plus our change in x from t equals
1 to t equals 3 and it would be 4 plus
our change in y
so this is going to be equal to 3 plus
our change in x well that's going to be
approximately 3.22
and 4 plus our change in y that is what
52.4
this right over here is 52.4
but we still have to answer this first
question what is the magnitude of the
displacement was a pythagorean theorem
i'll draw a very rough sketch of what's
going on sometimes it's useful to
visualize it
so our initial position is at three
comma four
so three
comma
four
so we're right over there and we figured
out our change in x isn't much so our
change in x is a positive 0.22 so our
change in x we're barely moving in that
direction and our change in y is 48.4 so
we have a dramatic change it really goes
off the charts over here in that
direction but if we wanted to add them
together
if we want to add those vectors together
you could shift over your change in y
right over here and then find the
hypotenuse the length of the hypotenuse
would be the magnitude of the entire
displacement and so let's do that
so our the magnitude of the displacement
is going to be the square root
of our change in x
squared plus our
change
in y squared once again this is just the
pythagorean theorem and what is this
going to be i'll get my calculator out
again for this
okay that was our change in x
let me square it
and then plus
we are going to have 48.4 8.4
squared
is equal to this right over here and
then we take the square root of that
so this is going to be
see if we
right over there and there you go our
total the magnitude of our total
displacement is
48 we round to the nearest tenth 48.4
so this is
approximately 48.4
and we're done
now one thing that you might be noting
is hey it looks like our total
displacement 48.4 is the same as our
change in y
now the reason why it came out this way
is because our change in y was exactly
48.4 while the magnitude of our
displacement was slightly more than 48.4
but when we round to the nearest tenth
we got to 48.4 the reason why they're so
close is because our change in x was so
small we're talking about 0.22 as a
change in x and our change in y was so
much that our hypotenuse was only
slightly longer than our change in y so
that's why we got this result for this
particular instance in general you're
going to see the magnitude of the
displacement is going to be larger than
the magnitude of either x
our change in x or change in y alone